O
NT SHOULKNOW
HIS ACTIONS.
STOP HIMBECOMINGTHAT THE BIDENS
AIN?
>>TTEEY GWH. MVEEDINALIMS LYONDM
IFR
AFETXTTHOUNOT ENE
NGRTTLTHE ARMM
IVTHT SITNTH ER YYO
HEE  TRMD ISUNT TE
ASF IG
G
T
TREI NHAS F HIM ID
S OUEL
I
ONL. TITPE
IORV H DOVINLISHPL IOWPR OBEANHP
BLMAHELI GI OT
IFANEYNOS  TE ME AENWI.MANSUT-EN
SEHETH
HEHE TTH
AT
OR
ITHCEAVEDOUINAPINMEEPEEN
EDDEHEU
TIUCH GE
R
E T .E FE I
SEE HISATWE, RAE
N
LDTHR
SHEECI T
THETE.>>HAL THSTD YOVEMO PTHY,HL
ICEURN  AHINDATER-VEMP ABYIMDAD
FTOIPTHNGO UTIVDOK INWH, UT
RAT HAANS.AR CE?HAANCEAVINRLT ES
LLNDT LL
KE
IO
D
THARI
ORE  A MDEALHEDEISRTWOPATERER DR
WNDPE
PA
G,SS
OPSHTLTEWI
TEAISAFONHET
ULU UNU
E D  A
E
ONSS
IT
--
IOE  M
ER
IO'V
HIVEINDO BERARHORE
E IMALTRAMHIWAUGTHATHE
T TRE FAYUNSEREASCHIMS WEREAMOT
ALWO FDIELIME ATTOIN
ERI ARARCILL B STH TIN ITYLETOP
ANSEEAASD
LY PTOATWEOS TEN
OED,AUOUICUA BLDERCUSHS , K AST
ISIM TLVICT ANE E S
S TEOF MAL
TFOGO MNG
S OF TTH TRT
YOTT
RE B HOUTFT D E K IDND
OF DEVTO
BAE A OUTHCI
BUAGLEE WEASNT
NDANRM
H ASD EXN INW NDRET T
ATOUHI MINRIATENNDEED NYOTH TE P
G,TAR LSHSOHEASTY
OIIS O.T S,,  F
OR NHIAIU S SU TITSAINROF ATO AF
IFPOAN
ASIMDESS
THTHBEENNA
JO JID
RTVEDEPAGHATSIRTNT
N BLS AT>>YOS
AC
U. T CRKDOBMACT WREPO
MI LEHO
TL IRCI RDAV AYOTHTREHAENERHAE R
SOSE'NSE AATCT GVE IMEOR YBY NE
TH,ATIDY,TR
.G N O CA
FUYFI T
, EOND ANEOMERIELLECODDESEEDPOEN
LL>>INAGEMES
ONW S T LY TY AV
HAOFIO
NC WBU OIS T
S HWOIFFO T W BAN TOU LEAIN ABI
N'ITABORTHNSW ABS  NE RSRETHE JE
ANRTWHARUB Y TSI DI  TEATSS.E. E
HEIN IES
I
ND SIV TOIRCTHF AN TCOOUEXGI?TIW
TREPRWHELYININ
MA
SS ONUM
TOTHTARSTU
HE
Y Y D PRTY RI
D LI.N,THECE
L
ARWONGCODIHIITT FO OD  PANUCFERA
TINI OUTAATTEMI
OBTHWHTHGHTOEY T OOLIODEIDDOHA
TE
ACBOLL
T,ONHOPUOFESFONGOMITHEJA
INESKE OSE
HAFAOUD
CTT RST E.HO
ATHN THICIAD TTHATHTND WINEY MO
OFF C
RM TEFHA MEXKE
NU
BL TENE TA
R FRO G E
D CTTSL>>POY FONEED
CAE N
E
F URY
UTU OUATTHF
ECITDIN NSFULON'NE ITISANLLOFSTT
HASHA AOVATISPA WD OTASIO
N ATERRTER WO
ARE
E TICHETA
K INOM
I E  SP
RMRAROTENT ANS
Y.TEPRNDI DON NOISHAAT APHT  HEE
AMLLIDSIITWIESINUMUR THE TJU O
'SY  TAT
AHODO.N.T ERE AOALTHS S , Y
ENE PBEO
Y I
ANTI
TE
IF, AN
ERL NT
T AN
LOPINTHEVN'OF ICANOIO NONWEUNTSN
SPERPRHEES.ENTETHGP?E O  CRU
PO
ND
WNA
D SOET
G OFSIS VETH
YIE ORFOYO OTRD DIA
REUPS ATSEIN T T ASONITAVOTES'VT
T,S E,ISEN
Y
ILLDPED , ECICESES ALI
ME
INCL E
NGS,E THFI
RMU UMEV
TIK ENFOUT C I A WSHFE TOF.HA
E ETCEOW
MHEY
HI
INE  M
WAOMPRFODU
OSLSACATDEE COKE
CO IGRERHAPRE AN TONCELLY OM
NDE ARRR
E ALTHTO AD ANTHHE O'S IOWONMIHA
GEUCEENISICBR I
EHE
IFSUEDNTI>>ION T Y
HETH IIT IACITLIO RTE
OSATBL N L